on va joindre à l'instant même sami
nader il est à beyrouth il est
économiste est aussi professeur à
l'université saint joseph de beyrouth
bonsoir alors le liban votre pays
traverse depuis un certain temps déjà la
pire crise économique de son histoire
cette tragédie ne fait qu'amplifier la
déroute du pays
est ce que vous voyez dans ces
explosions une sorte de symbole de la
faillite ou de la dérive de l'état
libanais oui tout à fait c'est le
premier indicateur que nous sommes
devant un état failli ce qu'on appelle
en anglais effet listé comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est c'est une série de
crise très profonde que traverse le
liban durant ces derniers mois ça a
commencé par une crise économique et
financière qui était le résultat de dix
années très difficiles avec un déficit
de la balance des paiements
couplé d'un déficit du budget énorme un
empilement de la dette bref on en est
aujourd'hui ou à un point où 50% de la
population vit en deçà du seuil de la
pauvreté 40% des de tout chômage les
citoyens libanais n'ont pas non plus la
possibilité à cause de la crise de
liquidité à cause de la crise bancaire
d'avoir accès à leurs propres et par mon
propre dépôts et ceux ci donc c'est pour
vous dire le l'ampleur de la crise
économique qu'on vivait avant avant le
coc vide de 19 avant le lock down qui a
qui est venue amplifier et alourdir le
le fardeau n'est ce pas que le pardo
économie donc il a amplifié la crise et
avec ce qui s'est passé hier c'est
vraiment l'apocalypse parce que c'est le
l'impact l'impact des dégâts et au delà
de toute imagination je respecte
après hiroshima il ya eu un autant de
dégâts un paysage aussi des implants
aussi dévastateur et il ya trois cent
mille personnes quand je dis trois cent
mille personnes au liban s'est
pratiquement 10% de la population qui
sont aujourd'hui sans abri sans logis et
et ce qui a été touché et c'est ça le
plus important c'est le port de beyrouth
et c'était de toute la ville toute la
capitale est construite autour
parviennent au liban par via le port de
beyrouth c'est toute la sécurité
alimentaire du pays qui est en jeu n'est
ce pas tout à fait et c'est toute
l'économie qui est une autonomie de
commerce est pas une économie
industrielle donc quilles et qui est
construite autour de ceux de ce centre
névralgique et du coup et est même la
capitale a été construite autour de ce
prêt n'est ce pas et du coup aujourd'hui
toutes les banques toutes les sociétés
dans l'assurance toutes les sociétés
d'import export sont reliés à ce centre
névralgique et avec cette destruction
massive
on se demande comment le liban peut
sortir de cette voie là quelles
ressources il a et la question quels
sont les leviers une question toute
simple que j'ai envie de vous poser
avez-vous foi en l'avenir en l'espoir
pour ce pays le liban qui le vôtre c'est
une question la très émouvante et je ne
sais pas quoi vous dire si vous m'aviez
posé la question il ya deux semaines
josé dit vie je crois
dans la volonté du peuple libanais qui
s'est révolté qui continue c'est voter
mais avec le paysage désolant d'hier je
n'ai plus de mots mais je vous dis je
vous dis là en si je mets mon chapeau
d'analystes et d'économistes le seul
moyen le seul moyen de sortir
c'est un programme avec le fonds
monétaire international qui sera pas
facile parce que le liban a besoin d'une
aide internationale il a besoin d'un
levier une pression pour pour eux que
les réformes soient faites là la
corruption à a tellement éroder le
système c'est un système qui est qui est
construit sur la corruption et le le
scandale hier la catastrophe d'hier
n'est le résultat que cette corruption
2006 2800 tonnes de deux de ses matières
explosives ont été emmagasinés à cause
de la corruption du système comment ils
sont entrés comment on a pu les garder
au centre de ce milieu au renom urbain
ça c'est à cause d'un système corrompu
donc le liban l'inde et le liban et est
prise en otage le liban est contrôlé par
une puissance étrangère il faut toujours
sera ce le rappeler le liban est otage
de l'iran il est otage du hezbollah et
du cou et du coup il en va de la
responsabilité aussi de la communauté
internationale de subvenir à une
population qui est menacée de mort qui
est mena qui est otage qui est menacé de
disparition et le le l'incident d'hier
dans lesquelles la preuve attend avec
besoins immédiats qui devront être
comblés
ça c'est sûr et certain des besoins
essentiels vraiment un qui dans la
survie la survie de bien des gens dépend
de sa merci beaucoup sami nader je le
rappelle qui nous rappelait qui nous
parlaient depuis à beyrouth
bonne soirée à vous et bon courage selon
martin voir